why is it when it's men
with men someone like Andrew take he has
more power and he goes on a platform and
he preaches learn the difference between
the good woman and that woman now the
whole downfall of his platform is him
choosing to deal with women who weren't
really so what if the woman's a dating
coach
so if she's a dating coach and gives
dating advice and then gets raped or is
it on her now because she didn't know
the difference I just I don't really
care if that's what you think I just
hope you have the same energy for women
and that's my point is like women don't
really feel Sympathy For Men I feel
sympathy for women but not men do